[Music]
what advice would you give to your
younger self oh there's so much I would
say
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Jojo Gomez and I'm a
professional dancer choreographer in Los
Angeles California do I look okay I have
a planet on top of my head this is a
nice croissant today I started dancing
when I came out of my mother I thought I
was Britney Spears had a lot of energy
as a kid so my mom was like oh my god we
have to put her into dance class I have
choreographed for Demi Lovato
Tinashe I've worked with Charlie puth I
choreographed a video for dr. Phil's son
Jordan Brock Backstreet Boys I can't
believe that's on my list and love them
[Music]
my style of dance is super passionate
energetic raw and animated I love being
different
I love showcasing my different emotions
and I used to just do jazz funk and then
once I started training more on other
styles I received so much more
inspiration and year after year I just
become weirder and weirder and I'm kind
of embracing it right now
I've taught it so many studios all over
the country which I'm so blessed to have
had that opportunity I now teach every
once in a while at the Broadway Dance
Center and I actually trained as a
dancer there so it's completely
mind-blowing for me to be on the other
side now as a mentor I try to get my
students to have an experience rather
than striving to be perfect because
they'll never be perfect and I think
that's a beautiful thing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
we're in an industry where we're gonna
hear a lot of noes and when I realized
that it was all about what you looked
like that was when it really really
affected me because I'm Latin and Greek
I'm not meant to be a stick
I've always been curvy my weight as
always fluctuated and instead of
embracing it I always struggled with
body image I was always looking for
things to change about myself when I
would hear an O at an audition okay so
what do I need to change like maybe if I
spent 30 more minutes at the gym last
night I could have booked this job and I
went crazy so that was something I
really needed to work on because I hit a
breaking point where I was so unhappy
and I stopped believing in myself and I
had it completely changed my mentality
and say wait I can make my reality what
it is with the present body that I have
with Who I am right now and I have to
love myself sometimes it's really gonna
sting if people bully us or talk about
us but maybe we can try to embrace that
no matter how bad it gets and use them
as a fuel to our fire because everybody
loves a hater every once in a while
[Applause]
[Music]
when we dance we want to be successful
but sometimes when were in that hustle
we forget about why dance makes us truly
happy and that's something that I needed
to figure out for myself because jobs
they come and go you'll be on that job
for a week but dance is with you forever
[Music]
if I could give any advice to aspiring
dancers always embrace your
individuality don't try to be somebody
else always be you and be fearless Lee
you unapologetically you and just never
give up
[Music]